this is two years ago I played my 20
000th game on leechas
and this is what lafong had to say about
it
I think the game itself was really worth
it like I could have blundered in 20
moves you could have blundered in 20
moves but we ended up producing like a
super instructive game with a little bit
of everything right we have a super
destructive end game we have uh
isolated pawns double pawns King that
can't Castle Bishop pair the whole thing
I completely agree and gust appearance
from your cat
[Music]
okay so we're about to play La Fong
for his 20 000th game on the chess we
can see here
he is one game away and whatever happens
hopefully it's gonna be a fun one
hopefully no like
eight move Berlin draws
but no promises
I don't think he plays Berlin
I don't think I play Berlin
okay I'm whites
I'll probably focus more on the game
than on chats
and this is ten plus five La Fong's
twenty thousand
and I'm gonna play E4
and I'm expecting Sicilian
and then we'll see how it goes from
there
I mean the game that we played
almost three years ago was also Sicilian
but I'm I'm gonna play a different line
I still got some coffee not much coffee
left but a little bit
he's probably deep in thought right now
complicated position oops okay
muscle memory almost took over there
but I'm playing an alican Sicilian
which is
uh it's an opening that I played
in Beale as like a surprise weapon
and it has some similarities to ponziani
like trying to take over the center
right away
[Music]
so there's uh these d-pawn moves
whatever black does I take
and then Castle
[Music]
so this is like a kind of branching
position there's a lot of different
moves for black
there's C4 there's Bishop E6 there's a
G6 there's a bishop G4 there's Pawn E6
um my game in Switzerland recently
featured Bishop E6
I wonder if he knows that
I'm trying to remember what I played in
that game I think I'm supposed to take
oh there's a few moves here there is
takes and then
um this idea A4 I think I'll go for that
like have some vague preparation
the idea is to Simply kick the knights
gain space
so this is
I mean this is a position I've never had
before
although I I have had this in my like
pep file at some point I just
don't know so much Beyond this
um so I think one reason for
this early Apon thrust is I want to
provoke the Knight to D5
and only then play D4
and that way I avoid the isolated
Queen's Pawn
so playing relatively quickly here
and getting in the
early opening idea
now I'm a bit underdeveloped on the
queen side
wondering probably makes sense to take
first
but even though I'm underdeveloped on
the queen side black is underdeveloped
on the king side
and the King's not Castle yet to relax
so maybe that's some source of
of uh
possibility for me to attack
or at least try and like restrict black
from casting
for example G6 maybe I can take and play
Queen D4
thank you to go far man
I'm gonna try and go far in this game
oh this is wait this is casual
I hope this still counts for his number
twenty thousand I think it should
because
his recent games were also casual
yeah we're reaching a position where I'm
gonna have to start like figuring things
out on my own
um and nice thing about having the pawn
here is there's potential for Asics to
maybe destabilize the queen side a bit
more
he goes for E6
which looks solid
and now it's time to think
I mean taking on
on C6 doesn't seem too productive
Queen G4 comes to mind but then Knight
F6
so I think it's a question how to
best develop
um looking at A6 B6
and some eventual C4 move is interesting
hmm
and he just wants to play Bishop E7
so maybe I do play A6 first
like there's some argument that the like
after B6 my Pawn could be a liability
but it's also potential strength
and there's a line here
c497 Queen F3 doesn't work because it
takes and Knight would defend the Rook
so what about Queen G4 first
and there's Queen A5 as well
or queen A4 I should say
Queen A4 actually looks interesting Rook
C8
and maybe Rook D1
that's rather than I'll Trust my
instincts
another move that just came to mind is
Rook Rook A4 which I kind of wish I
considered
that could have been cool to like lift
over especially if black is preparing to
Castle
[Music]
but the point of Queen A4 is to induce
Knight takes D4 after which I take back
and then the Bishops tie down
so trying to slow down blocks
Quest For King safety
and
yeah we're probably either gonna see
Rook theater takes and got their two
main moves
so let's take with Queen
my heart thing's still working
I think my heart was stuck at 95 beats
per minute for a while I think that app
just like disconnected
should be back though
okay
yeah okay down to 73 that's better
yeah Knight F6 we might be going into
some end game
I don't really want to trade Queens but
I mean there's Bishop E3
Bishop B3 tick tick
I would love to somehow prepare Rook D1
without trading Queens but that's
difficult to do
there's Rook A4 still to consider
I think I like the idea of
Bishop E3
what's happening
Bishop B3 Bishop E7 Rook D1 takes takes
Castle
Knight D2 so we just got a position
okay
it's gonna be positional
Queens are traded
one benefit I didn't mention this before
when I played A6 but it's something to
keep in the back of mind
um with upon an A6 it fixes
the a Pawn on a dark Square
and that combines well with this bishop
situation
like with Bishops of the same color you
don't really want your pawns fixed on
the same color as your Bishop
so like
in very distant end game scenarios there
might be ideas of sacking on B6 to get
the pass a pawn
thank you
always something to keep in mind
not to mention there's ideas of like
bringing the Knight to B5
oh that move I should have considered
I think I was expecting
I thought I thought I could just take
and take but
yeah there's Knight takes and
oh what to do
and maybe it's still okay
two of my faves playing each other is it
my birthday happy birthday
so
yeah I kind of overlooked
Bishop C5
takes Knight takes takes takes
oh there's an interesting line though
so the calculation is takes takes takes
takes and then here and then Knight
takes and then here and that's winning
for white because Knight's attacked
Knight C7 is an idea
so let's say after Knight E3 there's a
knight B3 Rook a two
I'm still getting the Knight to
B5 in these situations
I think I go for that
it's not at all like a crazy tactical
game but it's it's very interesting from
a strategic point of view
um mainly because of the situation on
the queen side
it's like very long term where
this could be a weakness it could be a
strength
I think for the time being it's not in
any danger like the pawn is basically
defended by the tactic
so again if Knight takes I play this and
then I'm trying this and
um if the night moves I I fork
and really I just want to play Knight B5
and Tie Down The Rook to defending the
pawn
now there is going to be a question
coming up let's say I play Knight B5
uh the question will eventually become
do I want to play B4
wow
that move I did not see coming
hey I think you munch us appreciate the
raid
completely forgot calcium greenside was
possible but that makes a lot of sense
because now the king's gonna come to B8
it's a good Defender
I think I still should go for this
and the Knight will come probably to D4
some B4 idea still
so what's happening B4
b494
[Music]
ABC oops must Mouse up something there
I also have this move
and this is really interesting because I
have ideas of
this listen and this
for me I started with Knight D4
and in the process I'm also of course
writing this
so
we'll probably see either King C7 or
Rook D6
but I think against either move I I just
have the straightforward plan of getting
the pawn to B5 and getting the Knight to
C6
and light comes here the king will
either have to go into the corner or be
prevented from coming to B8 and then
then A7 becomes a bigger Target
so we've both Fallen below five minutes
but there's still the increments so
it's a lot of things that can
still happen probably no dirty flagging
today
or at least in this game I should say
did I repeat
that would be still anticlimactic for
his 20 000th game
but I think I repeat once
although I kind of want to play
B4 first
let's repeat once
again a little bit of time
I'm putting the ball in his court
because psychologically he would
probably be sad if
his 20 000th game ends in some
repetition before move 25
but uh yeah B4 I think is going to be my
next move regardless of whether he plays
this or this
if he plays Rook D6 and King C7 is no
longer coming
foreign
Night Moves B5
oh but the pawn could be attacked
I actually have to calculate this
now the pawn gets attacked
so b494
B5
might be
might not be good for me
so maybe after 94 I play Knight B5 King
B8 F3 first
foreign
yeah I'll still go for this
expecting 94.
the problem is 94 friends to take the
pawn
[Music]
and then has ideas of removing the guard
of the night
like I want to play B5 but after it
takes
I think it's better just to throw in the
check
but then
some annoying night move
I have to go for this
so now after three
I might be sacking a pawn
it gets really interesting though
so Knight E6 Knight D4
Rook C8 B5 Rook C3 Knight here
King goes in the corner and then
maybe have to defend first
it's hard to judge from a distance
I guess I want to I could just defend
with Rook C1
and the event of Rook C8
and it's hard for black to actually stop
the planet B5 Knight C6
and it would actually be nice if I get
in like a structure of
C4 B5 not on C6 Rook on C1
that's the ultimate dream
so yeah I'm leaning more towards
I guess it's a question which Rook to
put on scene one
okay here I could play C4
oh which maybe just plungers a pawn
I might be considering B5 here
so if I played B5 myself
I think I could play B5
my B5 E5 though
that's not so simple
so B5 E5 no B5 E5 Knight C6 and I hit
the Rook
I think I do play B5
maybe he sucks Exchange
I mean I'm working towards my goal
I'm getting like full domination
foreign
is still kind of a threat
could consider playing
C4
I kind of like the idea of Rook
let me Rook B1 first
I'm trying to get a grip on the position
I have to watch out for these Forks
Knight C4 I probably play Rook D1
maybe even Rook B4 there
I Rook B4 looks nice
okay so now Knight C6
maybe in no rush
oh he wants to play E5
I have their
I could play F4
hmm
there's rookie one as well
your rookie won
huh
foreign
tricky
for take
Rook D1
I played Rook B4
although
I'm not seeing it
let's play that for him
it's a panic move
um
foreign
C6
take take
I have to try Knight C6
so Rook D5 C4
hmm
not sure what to make of this
it's probably very close to a draw
it probably should be a draw although
I'm not sure
am I King out
through the power of kung fu all things
are possible
that was a bad move though I'm in
trouble
King C4 is coming
maybe it's still playable
trying to make it so it's not good for
him to take
or if you take sign I guess counter play
this is a nightmare scenario my pawns
are now weak and so they're strong
together
I'll try this
desperation though
maybe I've I found some trick
they get to C7
wow this is threatening made in one
that's insane
take
wow
foreign
this is a pretty classic draw actually
um looking for final tricks but
I think I'm fine just pushing
I have to be careful actually but
yeah B2 Rook B1
I think black was very close to winning
there
at some point
Maybe
I could I think this is still a draw
but let's just take
um
I could play this hoping that he
no let's just play this okay
okay there's there's a situation but uh
yeah that was not gonna happen
there's a situation where back could
over push in one way
that's when the king is further away
okay good game
okay let's see if this works
hopefully people can hear
hello hey lafong there you go hi Eric
hey good game oh wow what a game
that was like a very
um
how to describe it like very strategic
I think some very instructive moments in
the end game
there is a moment I think you were very
close to winning in the end game
yeah after I played G5 and H6 I thought
it was winning but I couldn't find a way
you want to maybe jump into a study or
something yeah sure thanks for not
repeating the
Knight d49b5 of course
I I was wondering if I um if I went for
repetition if you would go out of your
way to avoid it I thought maybe you'd
play Rook D6 but if I run D6 Rook D1 and
it's unpleasant right yeah it is
unpleasant for the night uh-huh kind of
coming into
the weaknesses
so I've um I was like never played the
C3 Sicilians uh an opening I've been
learning more of recently so I was
excited to try it against you
ah someone told me you had it in bill
yeah yeah I was um
I was mentioning this during the game
but uh a few weeks ago I played the bill
chess festival and I I prepared this as
a surprise weapon against one of my
opponents
um but that was my first time playing as
a retirement what's that
did you did you surprise him like did
you get what you wanted oh yeah yeah I
was playing a wgm from China and she
took like maybe five minutes on the
second move I think deciding between D5
and Knight F6 and she actually played
the same line that you played like this
bishop E6 move
and so Eric yep I'm gonna be very honest
with you
up until today's game I always played
Bishop F5 ah until I played Daniel and
tattle Tuesday next last week and I got
crushed hmm
so interesting I checked it and Bishop
E6 seems more solid than Bishop F5
yeah Bishop E6 I think is like the main
the main move in like Masters database
like most popular by far right
um yeah I actually learned the C3
Sicilian by looking at dania's opening
tree like just looking at all his split
schemes in C3 Sicilian and then mapping
out his repertoire and then kind of
modeling it for myself right so I see uh
E6 is can you tell me where did uh your
game and Bill was different than this
one like where did I play differently oh
so I I actually deviated from my own
game
I think in Beale I played D4 and then
okay it got weird like CD4 and then
there is some Knight A3
like we got some position like this
which is
it's playable like White's pressuring
black because the Queen's misplaced
white so they hadn't development my
opponent managed to equalize
but okay
um
I I was aware that there's a different
move after
Bishop E6
is to take take an A4 and
this is I think the top engine idea like
if you turn on socks yes it says A4 is
plus 0.3 so I was aware of this and I
like I I went with it basically just
knowing the ideas to play A5 and
eventually D4 and that was extent of my
prop
yeah and I think it's a really
interesting idea because from at least a
human's perspective it's very annoying
for black to have to face this Pawn on
A6 and be worried about A7 all the time
yeah like long term especially with
um like potential dark story Bishops or
even like the Knight ending which we had
um it seemed much more pleasant for
white
right so I see there's a Carlson nepo
game in this line
this is
I was not aware either but there is no
way that it was a game uh there's no way
that was a world championship game right
uh
yeah he definitely did not play the
elephant in the world championship this
was from 2020.
so okay uh the game was
from
oh it was from some online like Skilling
open and chest 24 thing
so they got a similar structure though
um because Carlson also got the pawn to
A6
so right
of course our game was a little bit
different
like here Carlson played Asics
immediately
but is this a transposition though
uh it's very similar so what happened in
our game you played E6
in the Carlson nepo game
he didn't play E6 until here
it's actually very similar
and queen G4 played okay well this is
the Carson Nepal game I see it here
right
yeah my idea was to go Knight F6 and
if you go Queen G3 you have Bishop D6
and Rook G8 if you take on G7 very
tricky so here here yes oh no my G7 Pawn
exactly ouch
yeah it's nice idea that was the way I
was gonna entangle and try to Castle
I
I took first and then I played Queen
wait a minute
oh I played D4 first
and it was similar yes
so we basically transposed
uh yes but the difference is you forced
me to take on D4 instead of taking on C6
so your your queen got into a nice
Square on D4
yeah this was part of my thought process
because I was debating between Queen G4
and queen A4 and I thought Queen A4 it's
just more direct because it like if you
take then I'm happy to take back with
Queen
and it's a little bit different
so it's almost a novelty
and okay so yeah yeah I I think on Queen
G4 I'm probably taking your knight
anyways
I see okay
but but I have less options when you go
Queen A4 so maybe Queen A4 is more
precise
because I know some ideas in these
structures where if you go Queen G4 I
have some H5 H4 ideas even
yeah it can get very sharp like very
quickly
so okay so Queen A4 so this is like
pretty new territory now
uh we trade
and then for some reason I just missed
that you could play Bishop C5
like I forgot you could take with diets
and just reinforce the bishop so but I'm
not sure how good this is because yeah
um ideally I wanted to have a quick King
run to C6 before your knight got to B5
right
and uh with my Bishop on f8 I'm also
controlling A3 so if I ever want to
trade Bishop versus knight it's also an
option
so I was not 100 sure
if Bishop C5 was the best move here I
was even debating coming back to D5 with
the Knight I wasn't sure here I see
yeah because what ended up happening
didn't seem super Pleasant for black
but oh really I well I I was not sure I
felt that I was pressured so
but but I didn't see anything that you
missed though
yeah let's um let's go for it because
we got to the structure I was happy to
get a knight B5 you didn't take my
um My Free Pawn which wasn't really free
no Eric I I uh and I forgot this is even
a bit uh
this um Queens I have to right yeah yeah
it makes sense uh defend the pawn
and then yeah I was I wanted to just
like mentally torture you with the idea
of repeating you did uh
get some time
but I figured yeah
[Music]
and then
and and what is crazy here is that you
are a move away from
from having a clear Advantage if you get
if you get your knight to C6 and I can't
do anything I'm basically dead right
yeah the problem is it's like
practically it's hard to actually
achieve that
um
because I had some
just concrete issues like after I play
B5
I want to play Knight C6 but you just
take on B5
oh I saw a line for you here I saw C4
yeah so C4 I was calculating but after
it takes
Knight C6 oh and then Knight C6
yeah you just sack a pawn and if I have
to play Rook 8 then Rook C1 and it's
really unpleasant right
yeah
[Music]
I guess I didn't want to take the risk
here
or maybe there is some
deserve Knight D6 but then
I'm trying to wrap my mind around this
situation like Knight G6 I take on a
takes seven
and yeah I guess you're just in time
with Rook C1 check right and then Knight
C6 also comes with check
yes
so when okay so C4 the line I calculated
here was Knight C8 for me and Knight C8
wow
yeah after 1966 Knight E7
oh that doesn't work you have 95. oh
okay but but I I saw Knight A7 and Rook
8.
gotcha that's kind of a clever way to
try and hold on yes but I think you have
night 95 here it's really uh unpleasant
yeah I wonder yeah I wonder if C4 was
the best route
I can I I haven't been using the engine
so
I might as well like check now and see
just check if it's the best move
uh C4
so somehow C4
Knight takes C4 and if Knight C6
oh wow there's Knight A5
oh 985 and King B8 just a blind spot
Square yeah King King B is idea wow okay
I didn't see that
and somehow that's even better for black
like here here
because yeah my pawns are going to be
more weak than they are strong I see yes
wow okay okay so so C4 doesn't work so
so is black fine here
so I played Rook a B1 yeah the engine
just says it's like equal
uh maybe a small Edge for light if I
play F4 but no it's very close equal
[Music]
okay
so
now it's saying you're better after
Knight C4 which is crazy
oh okay I I was only thinking about E5
forcing your knight to C6 and taking on
B5 and I I saw the line that we went to
and I thought the Rook end game was
actually good for me
yeah and it turned out to be good for
you
um yeah because my king is just closer
to your pawns right yeah I want to note
here that the the engine finds like an
advantage for back after Knight C4
Knight A5 and your Knight's just so good
on A5 oh that's so tough to find them
it's like
yeah because it's so easy to think about
this position and and try and find the
ideal Square for the night
and you think okay maybe C5 maybe
somewhere in the center but A5 is the
best Square
like preventing Knight C6 and then
ensuring that the C Pawn is backwards
right
so yeah I completely missed this idea
yeah so yeah and when you play before
obviously I'm still going for E5
yes yeah and then yeah it worked out for
you because it takes takes
maybe I I shouldn't go into C6 but I did
and then
okay so I'm curious I'm curious now
what happens in this end game
because
um Okay C takes King D6
so
oh no but you don't have the one check
because I go King Rook D5 so
yeah I think black is already like
definitely playing for a winier
yeah like when I saw this from a
distance I thought oh maybe I can still
play for a win because your A7 Pawn is
um gonna be a long-term Target but my
b-pawn is a bigger Target
and your kings is more active
um so is is King C5 Rook C1 check King
B5 lost
I didn't like this yeah because you win
both pawns yeah and then you hold on
roxy7 takes takes H5 yeah it's probably
lost right like I'm I'm just pushing my
beep on yeah I think this is a pretty
classic win because even if I got a past
Pawn the two passers for back are just
much longer I'm just gonna sack my yeah
yeah okay
so if you didn't have this then it
becomes difficult right because the
combination of The Rook on E5 and the
pawn on G5 was really powerful because
your king couldn't come in
yeah and that's kind of what you got in
the game
with the pawn on G5
and then I just had to wait like my only
idea is to wait until you take and then
get counter play with my Rook because I
can't do so right away
and then so here I had five seconds I
got excited when you play H4 but I'm not
sure yeah I mean H4 on my part was just
a panic move I think I was deciding
between H4 and Rook B2
um
but then what ended up happening so here
here hey Eric
can I wait here
can I play Rook C5 for an example Rook
C5
because you have no moves
I think maybe then I played I could play
Rook C5 and wait for you to play King F3
and then play H5 or something hmm
well or even maybe
even Rook G5 here
I think if if you wait then I can wait
with Rook B2
yeah but then I push the H Pawn
ah and when you play King G3 I play H5
I see
yes I guess if you wait I have to play
yeah G5 here is really good I think
Rook G5 and if Rook H1
and then
ah okay
but then just a king B5 right
you know take take and then Rook G6
ah and then this
yeah Rook C6 and I don't have oh
yeah Rook G6 is a key move
this is a really instructive Rook end
game uh we both didn't have time but
I think I I took B5 too quickly
yeah and I don't know if this is what
cost cost me the the draw
now I think you're you're definitely
right that like Rook G5 and I'm not
seeing
I'm not seeing any way for white uh even
fights because H3 is coming
yeah unless can I
do I have something like Rook B2 H3
and then keep waiting
then uh H2 and then this
and again I just taken Rook G6
take your so at least in this line I can
defend but
maybe it's yeah too late
um yeah it's probably not good because
you're gonna it's probably not good
right
mm-hmm
I can play King B4
yeah I don't know but that doesn't solve
my issue because you have a rugby to
check
uh but any move should be good here
yeah like black black should be on the
verge of winning because right even Rook
B2 there's uh King C3
and then B5 is coming
yeah
um
okay so after it should be five soon and
then yeah then I was happy to get this
check
yeah that was a mistake yeah but okay so
we got to this position
and there was a move I was really scared
of you played Rook B3
although maybe no now I see it was it H3
H3
um
maybe and then oh page five oh you have
G5 right
uh G5 yeah
yeah
uh seven
H2 Rook takes but your Pawn is fast
enough in that line let's say I sag the
two H pawns right wait what are we
looking at H3
h37 h5g H2 oh no no not H5 just just H2
oh H2 and then I take
yeah I think I'm too slow right like if
I
oh actually wait a second Rook A5 here
uh yeah Rook a five in this position
yes G5 I'm guessing yep
Rook A6
and then fg6 B5
um
um but I can take first
this seems to salvageable
but maybe not do I have Rook H6
this is absolutely messy here oh I have
I have table base open table base says
it's a draft or Rook B2 oh or a lot of
other moves even Rook H6
but practically maybe it's still
playable practically I mean I would
Panic as white here yeah
so maybe it's my best okay so I wanted
to just show you an idea that I was
scared of at least once we got to this
position
you can play a move that threads made in
one
oh Rook B1 Rook B1 just threatening
Checkmate like I can't take on E7 I
thought this was funny that your pawns
play a role
my king just like sandwiched in the
center uh-huh
so
Rook D7 check first and Rook A7
oh that's a good point
actually yeah I don't know why I was
scared of this
yeah
but but do I have Rook F1 check like
okay let's say I go King C5 yeah
take and if you take on A7 do I have
Uruk F1 and H3 because you're actually
your Pawn is pretty fast yeah H3 almost
your Pawn is fast too
Rook H7
but your Pawn's faster Rook C7 King D6
A7 oh
actually I don't know uh okay one
but then
Rook C1 Rook H1
no that's winning three yeah yeah
yeah yeah and games are tricky
so what is the engine saying after
you played Rook C7 yeah let's see any
win for black
it's saying that
Black's not completely winning but it's
minus 0.5 Rook B1 is the best move
and then actually the best line is the
one that we were just looking at
wow um
King yeah
waiting for black though
so where did we go wrong Rook C7 this is
all the Top Line
this is all fine actually
oh and then Rook H7
I'll take yes yeah yeah okay and then
you're getting the two H pawns get the
g-pawn yeah
yeah it's um
yeah more than enough to draw what a
game
I yeah I guess Jaws are fair result
right like I I blundered once I think I
think so we can uh we can run the uh the
engine analysis to the game reports the
report
sure I I do see the graph here so the
best
okay yeah I was at minus 3.8 that was my
best advantage
[Music]
oh wow so it was winning
wow yeah waiting with a rook so Rook G5
is one winning now G5 is winning right
but even stronger was Rook E7 just
giving no counter play
oh wow and then I'm kind of just stuck
yes
I had to be patient here I um I think I
was under temp pressure and I sort of
panicked here
I think the the plan after rookie seven
is to check push the H Pawn Yeah and
then win these pawns and
yeah simplify
I I think it was a pretty high quality
game for the most part
yeah yeah I mean the mistakes definitely
came much later
and very interesting
situation on the queen side from early
on
so yeah a lot of lessons to take away
like more high level lessons to take
away which is
that's a good thing
well Eric it was an absolute pleasure
I'm gonna continue
My Stream over here
all right but uh yeah thanks for
following it was a pleasure to meet you
thanks for this I really appreciate it
all right well have a good one
be in touch I'll see you soon all right
take care bye